-Hey, guys. We're hanging out
with Jon Hamm right here.
Now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know we were saying earlier,
you -- you were in a musical,
but you were never in a band.
-I mean, it's, like,
not entirely true.
-Yeah, a lot of people
don't know this,
but before our careers took off,
we were both in a --
-I just didn't want to brag.
-Well, we were both
in a band together.
-Yeah. I mean, I know. It's --
I should have brought it.
I should have brought this.
-What?
-I found one of our old touring
T-shirts the other day.
We were in a band called Burlap.
-Burlap.
[ Laughter ]
Burlap.
We were sort of, like,
an outlaw, country,
rock 'n' roll.
-Rock 'n' roll. Yeah, country.
-Yeah, but looking back,
I think we might have focused
a little too much on our image.
-No, no. It was a good look.
It was the right look.
I just feel like
that the songwriting
really needed a little work.
-Right.
People would come to our shows
based off of our look
and they expected to hear songs
about trucks and trains
and love gone wrong.
-Mamas and...
-Mamas. Yeah.
-But we did not write songs
about any of that.
-Not at all. No, we did not.
Well, you're not
gonna believe this.
-No.
Don't tell me you have a clip.
-[ Laughter ]
-I have a clip.
Here's the very first
performance of Jon Hamm and I
in our old band, Burlap.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tractorfest '99!
How y'all doing tonight?!
-Whoo!
-[ Cheers and applause ]
We are Burlap!
And just like the fabric,
we are rough, rugged,
and itchy as heck.
-Country style!
I see a lot of outlaws
in the crowd tonight.
What do you say we rock
this house across state lines?
-Ha ha!
I think we got just the song
to keep Smokey off our tail.
Hit it!
-One, a-two.
A-one, two, three.
-♪ I love, I love my lollipop ♪
♪ I love my lollipop,
I love my lollipop ♪
♪ I love, I love my lollipop ♪
♪ I love my lollipop girls ♪
-Thank you.
[ Audience jeering ]
-Oh, no. That's not...
Hey!
-Hey! Come on!
-I got to say...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I-I will say, that holds up
a lot better than I remember.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It wasn't bad.
-Yeah, it certainly
went a lot better
than our performance
at Bootscoot '99.
-Oh, Bootscoot. Guh!
A disaster!
I'm really glad
you don't have a clip of that.
-Well...
-No way!
-Let's look at another clip of
me and Jon's old band, Burlap.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright!
Bootscoot '99,
let's hear some noise!
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
In case our reputation
does not precede us,
we are Burlap,
and we're basically
musical chicken wire!
-Yes, sir!
It looks like we got us a lot
of rascals out here tonight.
But what do you say
we wrestle these varmints up?
-Country style!
-A-one, a-two.
A-one, two, three.
-♪ DVD collectors ♪
♪ We're DVD collectors ♪
♪ Like videotapes but on CD ♪
♪ We like collecting DVDs ♪
-♪ There's a lot to enjoy
about DVDs ♪
♪ Like bonus content
and commentaries ♪
-♪ Scene selection,
animated menus ♪
♪ The last DVD I bought
was "Meet Joe Black" ♪
-♪ DVD collectors ♪
♪ We're DVD collectors ♪
♪ We like videotapes but on CD ♪
♪ We like collecting DVDs ♪
-♪ Baby ♪
-That's right!
-Oh, come on.
[ Audience jeering ]
-Come on, now!
-Stop it!
[ Audience jeering ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
That was a crazy, intense show.
-It was.
-Yeah.
Uh, that was intense.
That was very intense,
very intense.
-Yeah, that was not
as intense as our --
as our --
It was not as intense
as our farewell.
-Our farewell --
Our third show.
-Well, yeah. Of course.
I'm talking about
Rustbucket '99.
-Oh, Rustbucket.
-Let's take a look.
The third and final
performance ever...
-[ Sighs ]
-[ Laughter ]
-...by Burlap.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Rustbucket '99!
Let's get rowdy!
-Whoo!
-Now, just in case
you didn't read
your commemorative
festival program,
we are Burlap, and our
tour bus is a wheelbarrow.
-Heh! Country style!
-Oh, man, you know,
you're always saying that,
but why don't you tell them
what "country style"
really means?
-Well, take a Little rock,
a little roll, a little rebel,
and a little rear tire damage,
then you smother that thang
in gravy.
-Oh, hit it!
-A-one, two.
A-one, two, three.
-♪ Java in my cup,
time to drink it up ♪
♪ Gotta have my coffee
or I get real grouchy ♪
♪ Grinding up the beans
just a splash of cream ♪
♪ Gotta have my coffee,
or I turn into a grump ♪
-♪ Americano, macchiato,
cappuccino, latte ♪
-♪ We don't give a hoot
if you like it or not-te ♪
-♪ Slide-whistle break ♪
♪♪
[ Slide whistles blowing ]
-♪ Now I slide your whistle,
you slide mine ♪
[ Slide whistles blowing ]
♪♪
Hey, come on, now!
Hey! Get off me!
-That's enough! That's enough!
[ Audience jeering ]
We're outta here! We try to do
something fun, and you guys...
[ Audience jeering ]
-Well...
-[ Cheers and applause ]
At least we went out on top.
-On top.
-My thanks to Jon Hamm!
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
-Whoo!
♪♪